I am mop mess Express but I gotta get my
ish together I'm coming off pills like
the Sears thing already since you are
the queen of YouTube scandals I want to
go through YouTube scandals and forgot
which one is the biggest of all time I'm
gonna give you two and then you have to
decide which one was more dramatic more
scandalous man EMU and laura-leigh vs.
jeffree star or James Charles vs. talk
to you and Jeffery star which scandal is
bigger lurid Mandy I'm sorry that people
got hurt you know it's never my
intention but that's what happened and I
take full ownership of that why and then
meanwhile literally be so racist like
that's crazy like people are mad at me
from ghosting I'm like someone thought
was all racist I was surprised by that
but I I definitely I see where it coming
from an emu and laura-leigh vs. jeffree
star or panic on people think I hate him
I actually genuinely love Hannah I like
love love love her but panic on that was
it show from the start I let so many
people down and I want to make it right
but I it's crazy this is not something I
ever thought would happen
my manager asked me to be a part of it
and I'll just like he'll know how in the
world are you gonna compete with VidCon
you're gonna have better security than
they got like no that was it that was
that was crazy that was more literally
like fire festival like there should be
a full documentary like on Netflix about
that that was insane so now we have
Tanner Khan or Logan Paul filming a dead
body oh oh really yeah I think the Logan
Paul thing was blown way out of
proportion
I don't even a Logan family I kind of
think he's kind of like kind of like a
little arrogant whatever
yeah the filming the type body is bad
but is it like canceled you don't mean a
lot of things I should have done
differently but I didn't and for that
I'm the bottom of my heart I am sorry
they're stupid and he was like what 20 I
probably would have filmed a dead body
when I was 20 you know what I mean I
think that one was so so so silly I
really do dog ten o'clock still holding
strong or the Jake Paul drama with
Alyssa violets
out of Spain she began a relationship
with my brother behind my back that was
so irrelevant like I know if you don't
know it then it's 10 o'clock or the time
joey graceffa parked in front of a
driveway you mentioned only being a
little bit in front of our driveway it
turns out I was blocking someone's
driveway by like that much that's just
not true in fact your entire damn car
was blocking our entire damn driveway
Joey here's a picture sorry Joey do you
remember that was the scandal of YouTube
that was big doctor for us and that
person was so mad and they like
literally even looking as a tax document
yeah you probably don't want to leave
your federal tax return lying out on
your passenger seat because any person
walking by can look in and see that you
owe $2,000 for 2012 oh that was scandal
I remember when that happened I was like
what's important I want to say Joey
but he's so um problematic so I'll say
okay she's holed it up yeah
Hanako Nora the time Sam pepper faked
the kidnapping cuz that was bad to house
it thinking let's see how he reacts to
his best friend of five years being
killed in front of him hah again because
it's like real people I'm gonna satanic
on put the same pepper I mean he was a
hot mess faking it
kidnapping is bad tentacle I'm still
holding up or recent the recent one when
Shane Dawson made that joke about a cat
and everyone was really upset about it I
was just like that one is so dumb so
telecon or when Morgan Adams started the
bird box challenge and the parents were
furious and concerned for the children's
well-being by the owner inside we can
see but if you open the door if you're
outside you have to be blindfolded I'm
gonna con on that so they're called
holds uh yeah that might be the ultimate
you to have congratulations to ten emoji
I'm telling it where to go
that proves right there like scandal it
is UPS you oh yeah so she's queen of
scandal
you